well do you have evidence that the FBI  might have uh planted planted something  anything at Mar-A-Lago seven weeks ago  you know what we know and I'm not going  to speak into details because because  you don't have any evidence even the  initial do you have evidence you know  what we know and I'm not going to speak  about details the answer is you have no  evidence that anything was planted it  would obviously be confidential and go  to the defense the case  um the attorney's handling it which I am  not but  as I have said on the show before  um I think the concern is that we have  recordings of these agents going in and  then we were not permitted to watch the  agents we see agents go in we see Agents  come out and we just don't know what of  what they took out was actually brought  in by them but do you have any evidence  but no no evidence but we just we saw  them go in and we saw them come out